latest numbers show about 160 people are  unaccounted for  following the partial collapse of that  beachside condo in florida  rescue crews pulled three bodies from  the wreckage overnight bringing the  death toll  to four the search for survivors does  continue  teams spent the afternoon tunneling into  the wreckage after dogs and  microphones picked up some banging  noises  so we concentrate in those areas it  could be just steel twisting it could be  debris raining down but not specifically  sounds of tapping or  sounds of a human voice friends and  family of the missing have been  gathering at a nearby reunification  center  they're posting photos on social media  holding out hope  there were prayers today for the missing  and for healing near the site  the cause of the collapse of that 40  year old building remains under  investigation